Every form of spirituality we can
identify whether it's traditional
religious forms of spirituality,
a kind of a materialistic,
scientific worldview or progressive
spirituality in all its many phases as
in the last 50 years that have emerged
within American culture and elsewhere
have both dignities and disasters,
right?
The spirituality brings out the best and
the worst in humanity.
And so every one of these major
categories,
the,
the religious,
the secular and the progressive have
very beautiful and important
expressions.
And they also have dark expressions,
which we do well to avoid.
And I certainly feel that scientology is
a dark expression of progressive
spirituality or maybe even secular
spirituality.
It's not really clear how to categorize
it,
but,
uh,
it is a cult and we see cults of all
kinds.
Whenever you're dealing with something
that's ultimately true and real,
there's people can go astray.
They can be pulled into forms of
organization,
which are,
uh,
diabolical.
I had in the signs of a cult include,
uh,
um,
particularly strong personality who
wants everyone else to conform.
Um,
it,
it can include,
um,
intense commercialization in which it
seems more like a business than a form
of spirituality.
Uh,
I think that the best way we can protect
ourselves on the spiritual journey is by
taking an integral view of spirituality,
is seeing how spirituality evolves and
seeing how it can become stuck,
how it regresses.
And so if we look at scientology,
we can see that there's a lot of
negative fruits.
A lot of lives have been ruined,
a lot of false hoods had been projected.
And so using this test of their fruits,
we'd be able to determine right away
that that's the kind of spirituality we
would do well to avoid.
Ultimately,
I think spirituality is a,
is a personal affair.
And while we can socialize our
spirituality and be part of a spiritual
group,
the spirituality in its essence is
really about our own spiritual growth
and our own experience of that,
which is beautiful,
true and good.
And so,
uh,
maintaining our,
our prerogative as agents of evolution
and as indeed agents of our own
spiritual growth is one way we can
protect ourselves from,
uh,
the ways that we can be led astray in
the spiritual marketplace of ideas.